in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxanian, for July 4th, on which we commemorate the venerable Andrew Rublev,
the memory of the venerable André Rublev.
Saint André, the greatest of the Holy iconographers, was born in about 1360.
Desiring from his youth to become a monk, he went to the Holy Trinity Lavra,
which was at the time, under the direction of Saint Nikon.
The latter sent him to the monastery of Serpukov to his disciple Athanasios,
who gave Andrew the monastic habit.
After having been ordained to the priesthood, Athanasios having left for Constantinople,
Andrew returned to the Holy Trinity Lavra, to live there, under Saint Surgisus Wing.
It was there that he was initiated into the art of iconography, partly by Daniel the Black,
his fellow disciple and brother in Christ, who, being of Bulgarian origin,
passed on to him elements of the tradition inherited from Byzantium.
They then stayed frequently in Moscow, in the monastery of Saint Andronikos,
also founded by Saint Surgis, and where Daniel had begun his monastic life,
and linked themselves with Delphan, the Greek, the great master of the Moscow school of iconography.
They worked together there on the decoration of the church of the Nativity of the Mother of God,
and then on the Cathedral of the Archangel Gabriel in the Kremlin.
In 1399, George Demetrivich, the second son of Saint Demetri of the Don,
who was living in Svanigurid, had a church and monastery built in the city
and summoned the finest artists of the period to decorate them.
The frescoes in the Cathedral were given to Saint Andrew to execute.
In 1405, Delphan recalled them to Moscow Kremlin to paint the iconostasis of the Cathedral of the Annunciation.
Three years later, they worked together with Daniel the Black,
on the decoration of the Cathedral of the Dormition in Vladimir.
In about 1420, they returned to the Lavra and received from the abbot the obedience
of decorating the main church of the Holy Trinity.
Saint Daniel painted the frescos and Saint Andrew the iconostasis,
which bears the sublime icons of the Archangel Michael and Saint Paul,
and especially the famous icon of the Holy Trinity,
which it is said, Saint Sergeus himself inspired him to paint.
The two monastic iconographers gave evidence of such zeal for fasting and prayer
that they were filled with divine grace.
Entirely possessed by the love of God, they ever turned their spirits
and thoughts to the divine light which shone in the depths of their hearts,
having as their only care to translate in color on walls and boards,
the reflection of this interior contemplation.
On Sundays, when they were not busy painting, they would sit before the venerable icons
made by their holy predecessors, with joy and heavenly light flooding over them.
The Lord, therefore, glorified them in their last hour.
André fell asleep first in about 1427.
Then Daniel, falling ill in his turn, saw at the moment of leaving this life
his companion in great glory, who summoned him with joy to eternal and endless felicity.
They were buried together in the Andronikov monastery,
where they had worked on the decoration of the church.
All of the icons painted by Saint André are filled with grace
and some of them have proved to be miraculous.
The most famous, however, is undoubtedly that of the Holy Trinity,
painted for the Church of the Lavra of Saint Sergeus on the orders of Saint Nikon,
which the Council of the Hundred Chapters stated to be the model for all Orthodox icons,
in the year 1551.
The Saint here far surpasses the evocation of the appearing of the three angels to Abraham
and represents with incomparable art and unequaled theological power,
the ineffable love that unites the divine persons.
The circular movement, suggested by the inclination of the angel's heads
and the tree in the background, as well as the inverse perspective
which directs the vanishing point to the viewer, makes the believer,
who stands devoutly in front of this icon of icons, a participant in the dance of the divine choir.
He is invited to take a place at this table as the fourth guest
and to taste of the cup delicately indicated by the angel in which a burnt offering can be seen,
a symbol of the Eucharistic banquet through the prayers of our Holy Fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.